turning now to a story about
perseverance five siblings now calling
las vegas home after leaving their
parents behind in afghanistan in order
to escape the taliban victoria saha has
this exclusive story you will only see
right here on 8 news now
imagine being stripped away from the
only home and culture you know and be
placed in refugee camps until you
finally get to call a place home while
for these five siblings calling las
vegas home was quite the journey from
the moment they left kabul over the
summer
the world watched in horror when the
people of afghanistan tried to make a
desperate flee from the taliban regime
it was like completely die like
everybody don't care about dying but the
fakiri siblings were amongst the crowd
being shoved and pushed to make it
closer to the kabul airport gates out of
respect for their culture we will not be
showing the teen girl's face
we was waiting like for eight eight days
outside of airport
just in front of the door of airport in
capital fifteen-year-old fahim fakiri
tells me through a translator he is the
oldest amongst the five siblings the
youngest is five the american army only
let them through
we didn't saw like my father and mother
like
in that time we just everybody pushed
like the
running the heartbreaking journey alone
to america started for the siblings once
in qatar a call came to their uncle who
lived in las vegas
the case manager reached out to me and
said that your
your niece and nephews are here are you
taking the responsibility for us to
travel them to the united states the
answer was an instant yes
i could not live with myself
and be able to have that piece of bread
and piece of food for myself to eat that
knowing the fact that there's five
innocent kids without a destiny without
a future somewhere four months of
paperwork and legalities finally allowed
the siblings to make their way to las
vegas
when i saw them at the airport it was an
overjoy of you know overwhelming joy as
the siblings adjust to life in their new
home they spend their time with their
cousins and play cards
and sing
but they say they worry about their
parents
we miss them
so it's so difficult for me
so we can't forget them
the home the family now lives in came
thanks to a local charity called the ari
foundation the siblings are able to
communicate with their parents regularly
but say things back at home are still
very unsafe denise